jetzt hoffe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 3a und 3b erste
beratung des von den fraktionen der spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp
eingebrachten gesetzentwurf zur änderung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes
und weiterer gesetze anlässlich der
aufhebung der feststellung der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite
sowie erste beratungen des von der
fraktion der cdu/csu eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs zur verbesserung des
schutzes vor impfpass fälschungen für
die aussprache
wurden 67 minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne damit die aussprache und als
erstes hat das wort der bundesminister
olaf scholz für die bundesregierung
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren das virus ist
noch unter uns und bedroht die
gesundheit der bürgerinnen und bürger
und deshalb ist es ganz ganz wichtig
dass wir alle maßnahmen ergreifen um
sicher zu sein dass wir die gesundheit
der bürgerinnen und bürger unseres
landes schützen können auch wenn die
lage anders ist weil so viele geimpft
sind ist sie noch nicht gut ganz
besonders deshalb weil nicht genügend
bürgern und bürger von der
impfmöglichkeit bisher gebrauch gemacht
haben und deshalb müssen wir weiter
vorsichtig sein wir müssen vorsichtig
sein und bleiben und zb dafür sorge
tragen dass die massen pflicht weiter
beachtet und durchgesetzt werden kann
das in verkehrsbetrieben sie genutzt
wird oder bei veranstaltungen das
abstandsregeln gelten die gene regeln
impft nachweise vorgelegt werden müssen
all die dinge die wir schon kennen sie
werden auch weiter für die nächste zeit
erforderlich sein und das ist ein
unterschied zwischen unserem land und
anderen ländern die sich entschieden
haben ganz auf solche vorsichtsregeln zu
verzichten wir halten sie weiter für
erforderlich
und wir müssen noch darüber hinaus viele
viele weitere maßnahmen ergreifen die
notwendig sind damit wir durch diesen
winter kommen wir müssen gewissermaßen
unser land winterfest machen
deshalb bin ich über einige dieser dinge
und maßnahmen sprechen die jetzt
erforderlich sind über die in diesem
gesetzespaket zu entscheiden sein wird
und auch über die maßnahmen die darum
herum auf den weg gebracht werden und im
rahmen der gesetzesberatung noch
dazukommen werden das aller erste und
wichtigste ist wir dürfen nicht
nachlassen bei dem versuch möglichst
viele bürgerinnen und bürger zu impfen
es haben sich noch nicht alle überzeugt
dass das für sie richtig ist und wir
sollten eine große gemeinsame kampagne
starten dass die bürgerinnen und bürger
von dieser möglichkeit gebrauch
die hausärzte die mobilen angebote sind
da und wir brauchen wieder mehr
impfzentren wir müssen dafür sorge
tragen dass sie wieder eröffnet werden
und wir sollten auch gemeinsam dafür
sorge tragen dass die eröffneten
impfzentren auch gemeinsam auch mit
mitteln des bundes finanziert werden
und wir brauchen sie auch weil wir
natürlich jetzt alles dafür tun müssen
dass millionen bürgerinnen und bürger
eine auffrischungsimpfung bekommen dass
sie sich boostern lassen dass millionen
bürgern und bürger die
auffrischungsimpfung bekommen das ist
die aufgabe der nächsten wochen und
monate
und auch dazu und auch dazu wird es
erforderlich sein dass wir diese
möglichkeiten haben die aktivitäten der
hausärzte die mobilen angebote und die
impfzentren und wir sollten das möglich
machen passiert in einem gemeinsamen
schreiben des bundesgesundheitsministers
und der ärzteverbände an alle hausärzte
und ärzte formuliert worden ist nämlich
dass man nach sechs monaten eine
auffrischungsimpfung erhalten kann soll
und wir werden alles dafür tun dass das
auch tatsächlich überall in deutschland
möglich ist
ganz besonders ist es wichtig dass wir
jetzt dafür sorge tragen dass die
älteren schnell geimpft werden und die
dritte impfung bekommen die booster
impfung und darum will ich an dieser
stelle auch die pflegeheime ansprechen
die so wichtig sind das war nicht zu
ertragen was wir am anfang der pandemie
erlebt haben dass so viele bürgerinnen
und bürger erkrankt sind die in den
pflegeheim gelebt haben dass so viele
gestorben sind und das darf uns in
diesem winter nicht mehr passieren
deshalb müssen wir alle notwendigen
maßnahmen ergreifen damit das nicht
geschieht es muss täglich getestet
werden wir dort arbeitet und nicht
geimpft ist und alle besuchern und
besucher müssen einen test bekommen dass
es für die sicherheit der bürgerinnen
bürger die in den pflegeeinrichtungen
leben erfordern
und natürlich müssen wir auch
sicherstellen dass überall in diesen
bereichen gemustert wird dass die
impfung durchgeführt werden das ist
längst vereinbart und das muss jetzt mit
großer geschwindigkeit geschehen die
geschwindigkeit muss er zunehmend zu dem
was wir bisher haben und deshalb bin ich
sehr froh dass es hier das vorhaben gibt
dafür zu sorgen dass die durchsetzung
des boosters der auffrischungsimpfung in
dem pflegeheim auch ge monitor wird dass
wir für jedes einzelne pflegeheim wissen
wie weit es ist das ist die aufgabe die
wird ganz in deutschland durchsetzen hat
wir werden weiter dafür sorge tragen
dass an den schulen getestet wird und
wir müssen sicherstellen dass die
arbeitsplätze sicher sind darum haben
wir gespräche geführt mit den
gewerkschaften mit betriebsrat mit
vielen anderen mit arbeitnehmern und
arbeitnehmern und mit den unternehmen
und wir sind sicher wir müssen eine
zusätzliche vorsichtsmaßnahmen am
arbeitsplatz treffen deshalb wollen wir
das in zukunft an arbeitsplätzen 3 gilt
man muss dort arbeiten werden an geimpft
ist genesen oder aber einen test haben
und das ist eine notwendige verbesserung
und auch das muss jetzt geschehen dass
wir die möglichkeit nutzen die mit dem
neuen gesetz verbunden sind dort sind
den ländern alle kompetenzen eröffnet
damit sie differenziert nach den
einzelnen bereichen entscheidungen
treffen können über 3g konzepte für den
zutritt zu gaststätten zum beispiel zur
veranstaltung zu geschäften und allen
möglichen aber eben auch zu zwei geben
und ich habe das so verstanden dass
viele länder sich jetzt auf den weg
gemacht haben um überall bei sich
entscheidungen treffen dass sie
insbesondere bei gaststätten und
veranstaltungen bei kinos und theater
besuchen zweig vorschreiben wollen ich
halte das für einen guten fortschritt
dass das überall gemacht wird die
möglichkeiten dafür schaffen wir jetzt
für all das was jetzt notwendig es gilt
aber auch eine sache ganz entschieden es
muss auch umgesetzt werden deshalb ist
es so wichtig dass wir das monitoring
machen im hinblick auf die
altenpflegeeinrichtung und einrichtungen
der eingliederungshilfe
aber deshalb ist es auch wichtig dass
wir sicherstellen dass an den
restaurants in deutschland tatsächlich
die zutritte auch überwacht werden es
kann nicht sein dass wir solche
vorschriften haben und jeder geht ein
restaurant und merkt dass sie nicht
beachtet wird gilt nicht für alle aber
wird an vielen stellen
damit man diesen weg gehen kann damit
wäre deutschland winterfest machen
können ist es aber auch wichtig dass wir
den bürgern und bürgern die
rahmenbedingungen zur verfügung stellen
die für sie es gestaltbar machen damit
umzugehen und darum bin ich froh dass
wir gemeinsam uns vorgearbeitet haben zu
der einsicht dass es notwendig ist dass
die möglichkeit kostenloser test für die
bürgerinnen und bürger wieder eröffnet
wird wir werden jetzt die voraussetzung
dafür schaffen dass es kostenlose test
gibt die zb in apotheken oder bei den
maltesern oder an anderen einrichtungen
verfügbar sind für die bürgerinnen
bürgern diesem lande dann sind nämlich
auch 3 gegen konzepte in den betrieben
und zweige vorschriften möglich und 3g
vorschriften alles das kann man machen
wenn man tests anbietet der stolze
erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage auf der
fdp-fraktion
und dann glaube ich müssen wir uns
natürlich damit auseinandersetzen dass
das virus eben nicht weg ist dass wir
all diese maßnahmen ergreifen müssen
aber es trotzdem dazu kommen wird dass
viele bürgerinnen und bürger sich
infizieren und ganz besonders diejenigen
die sich nicht habe schützen lassen und
die nicht geimpft sind wir sind in der
wirklich schwierigen situation dass wir
genügend impfstoff haben dass jeder sich
und jeder sich impfen lassen könnte aber
dass es keineswegs alle gemacht haben
bisher und wir wissen was die konsequenz
sein wird sehr sehr vielen von denen die
nicht geimpft sind werden sich
infizieren und viele von dem die sich
infizieren werden werden krank war und
von diesen die sich für ihm die krank
werden werden einige auf den
intensivstationen
unser krankenhäuser um ihr leben ringen
das ist die situationen die uns
bevorsteht und deshalb müssen wir hier
eine abwägungsentscheidung treffen eine
abwägungsentscheidung wie wir trotz der
tatsache dass
die impf angebote nicht wahrgenommen
worden sind uns um den schutz des lebens
dieser bürgern bürger auch mit allen
unseren möglichkeiten kümmern und das
hat eine konsequenz nämlich die
konsequenz dass wir sagen wir werden den
krankenhäusern die finanziellen mittel
geben dass sie jetzt operation neu
aufteilen können dass die operation
verschieben können die verschiebbar sind
damit sie platz haben für die korona
patienten die jetzt behandelt werden
müssen denn bei allem was man
unterschiedlich diskutieren mag über das
impfen wir müssen schutz für die
gesundheit aller bürgern und bürger
bieten und wir müssen ihnen diesen
schutz der krankenhäuser ermöglichen
das ist jetzt das gesetzespaket das wird
beraten hier im deutschen bundestag
es wird beraten zwischen den parteien
und ich will ausdrücklich sagen ich
finde es sehr schön wenn das
parteiübergreifend getragen wird weit
über die parteien hinaus die künftige
regierung bilden wollen das ist
jedenfalls die absicht und ich möchte
alle an den laden mitzumachen hier in
dieser wichtigen gesundheitskrise müssen
wir über parteigrenzen und über
regierung und opposition hinweg
zusammenarbeiten
und wir müssen und werden auch mit den
ländern sprechen und den gemeinden über
das was dann zusätzlicher unterstützung
notwendig ist und wie wir all das was
jetzt hier möglich gemacht wird auch
umsetzen das muss ja in der wirklichkeit
sich wiederfinden und deshalb wird es
auch die kanzlerin und ich sind darüber
einig wird es auch in der nächsten woche
ein gespräch ganz klassisches gespräch
zwischen der bundesregierung und den
ministerpräsidenten und den
ministerpräsidenten der länder geben um
die umsetzungsschritte genau zu
besprechen die sich aus all dem was hier
auf den weg gebracht wird ergeben wird
das ist das was wir jetzt brauchen dass
das land zusammenhält und an einem
strang zieht in eine richtung damit wir
diesen winter überstehen und mein
letzter wunsch an die bürgerinnen und
bürger die es bisher noch nicht gemacht
haben lassen sie sich impfen es ist
wichtig für ihre gesundheit und es ist
gesicht ich für unser land schön danke
ein impf appell des geschäftsführenden
bundesfinanzministers der er hofft in
wenigen wochen auch bundeskanzler zu
sein hat nochmal die vorsichtsmaßnahmen
beschrieben die weiter gelten sollen zb
3g am arbeitsplatz und das bringt uns
auch ganz schnell zu dem punkt dass auch
im bundestag im reichstagsgebäude
3g gilt und man also entweder nachweisen
muss dass man geimpft ist genesen oder
einen test beibringt und da sehen wir
noch mal die tribüne auf der all
diejenigen sitzen die einen dieser
belege nicht nachweisen wollen wir
liegen glaube ich ganz gut mit der
feststellung dass es sich hier über
linken fdp abgeordnete handelt jetzt
kommt eine zwischen intervention aus den
reihen der afg
eine zwischenfrage der afb die
berechtigte zuzulassen
meine frage
meine frage die sie vielleicht nicht nur
mir sondern auch der bevölkerung
beantworten sollten ist folgende wir
haben ja nun alle gelernt dass auch
geimpfte personen eine genauso hohe
virenlast tragen können wie ungeimpfte
sie haben von der 3g regelung am
arbeitsplatz geredet nun erklären sie
doch mal mir und auch der bevölkerung
welchen sinn das macht das geimpfte
personen nun nicht getestet werden
müssen wenn sie können ja andere genauso
gut anstecken wie ungeimpfte also ist
auch die frage warum ist es so dass
nicht entweder alle oder niemand
getestet werden muss das versteht
nämlich in der bevölkerung wirklich
niemand aber vielleicht können sie diese
frage mal beantworten danke
herr bundesminister möchten sie erwidern
gern auf ihre frage antworten erst mal
ist es so dass es wichtig ist dass man
sich impfen lässt weil das dazu beiträgt
dass man geschützt ist vor dem virus
aber wir wissen das ist ja kein
raumanzug den wir tragen sondern das ist
etwas was unseren körper in die lage
versetzt mit einer lebensbedrohlichen
gefahr besser umzugehen und dass das der
fall ist dass das der fall ist
das sehen wir an den ganz
unterschiedlichen
krankheitsverläufen derjenigen die
infiziert sehen das sehen wir an der
ganz unterschiedlichen betroffenheit
viel weniger geimpfte sind betroffen von
der infektion als diejenigen die sich
nicht haben impfen lassen und deshalb
ist es erstmal so ja es ist wichtig sich
impfen zu lassen und es führt dazu dass
man auch besser mit der sache umgehen
kann und dass die virenlast dann auch
typischerweise geringer ist weil der
körper schnell und zügig mit der
infektion umging
aber erstens wer sich impfen lassen und
sich trotzdem testen lässt wie die
meisten von uns ununterbrochen weiter
getestet werden macht nichts falsch
und zweitens
ich teste mich mehrfach die woche und
ich mache das auch oft weil ich zur
veranstaltung gebeten werden und alle
sagen lassen sie sich bitte testen mache
ich trotz meiner impfung und ich finde
das können auch viele andere machen und
selbstverständlich fände ich zum
beispiel dass wenn bei dem alten
pflegeeinrichtungen jemand als besucher
kommt und wenn er dann getestet sich
testen lässt trotz seiner impfung dann
ist das keine schlechte sache also das
sollten wir schon alles mit dem blick
haben
was sie machen was sie machen ist
merkwürdige konstruktion die alle immer
an der sache vorbei gehen zu fabulieren
konstruktion die darüber hinweg reden
dass das einzige was dazu beitragen kann
dass wir die gesundheit dieses landes
und der bürgerinnen und bürger schützen
können ist dass sich möglichst viele
impfen lassen und für jeden einzelnen
ist es auch die beste lösung schönen dar
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
ralph brinkhaus
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die zahlen die uns heute morgen erreicht
haben sind dramatisch über 50.000
neuinfektionen es ist so dass die
hospitalisierung zahlen zeigen es ist so
dass wir die hilferufe von den
intensivstationen gegen übrigens nicht
nur von der krankenhausleitung sondern
auch von den pflegerinnen und pflegern
die einfach nicht mehr können das muss
an dieser stelle auch mal gesagt werden
wir haben eine viel zu hohe todeszahl
sie hat sich gegenüber dem august 10
fach und wir sind in einer situation wo
viel zu wenig menschen hier in diesem
land noch geimpft sind es ist so dass
die dritte impfung ich mag das nicht
über booster impfung zu sprechen so
astrid info dass diese tritt in form
nicht gut genug organisiert sind das
heißt wir stehen vor einer riesigen
problemlage wir stehen vor einer vierten
welle wir sind in einer vierten welle
und deswegen ist es auch richtig dass
wir das nicht nur einfach durchlaufen
lassen sondern dass wir hier und heute
im deutschen bundestag darüber ernsthaft
debattieren das ist dringend dringend
notwendig und herr scholz ich finde es
auch richtig dass sie sich jetzt als
wahrscheinlich zukünftiger kanzler
endlich auch dieser diskussion gestellt
haben dass sie endlich was gesagt haben
aber ich muss ihn einst konstatieren das
war mehr eine zustandsbeschreibung als
eine kraftvolle politische außenpolitik
und es ist auch richtig und es ist auch
gut und richtig dass wir uns die zeit
dafür nehmen wir haben ja eben einen
hauptausschuss eingesetzt ist es richtig
dass wir auch eine anhörung machen es
ist alles gut es ist auch richtig ich
habe es gerade vernommen dass die
ministerpräsidenten sich jetzt endlich
nächste woche dann auch mal mit der
bundesregierung treffen das lag übrigens
nicht an die cdu csu ministerpräsidenten
sondern herr müller sitzt ja auch hier
im plenum es lag an den spd
ministerpräsident und ich hätte es als
respektvoll erfunden das bevor wir über
dieses gesetz abstimmen bevor wir über
dieses gesetz beraten die
ministerpräsidenten sich zusammengesetzt
hätten weil wir dieses problem nur
zusammen mit bund und ländern lösen kann
meine damen und herren
aber was nicht gut und richtig ist er
stolz ist das was sie hier als
gesetzentwurf eingebracht haben sie
haben eine sache konsequent ausgelassen
sie haben nämlich den menschen in diesem
land nicht verraten dass es ihr hund ist
dass es der wunsch der ampel ist dass
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite die grundlage die
rechtssichere grundlage die verlässliche
grundlage für unsere pandemie politik
auslaufen sollen da haben sie kein wort
darüber verloren und wurde jetzt
irgendwelche zweifel kommen warum wir
diese epidemische lage brauchen ich
zitiere mal aus dem gesetz was wir hier
haben die paragrafen 5 des
infektionsschutzgesetzes da heißt es
eine epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite liegt vor wenn eine ernsthafte
gefahr für die öffentliche gesundheit in
der gesamten bundesrepublik deutschland
besteht weil eine dynamische ausbreitung
einer bedrohlichen übertragbaren
krankheit über mehrere länder in der
bundesrepublik deutschland droht oder
stattfindet meine damen und herren was
ist denn die situation ist denn hier
irgendjemand der meinung dass kobelt
nicht übertragbar ist außer die afg ist
irgend jemand der meinung dass kobelt
nicht bedrohlich ist ist irgend jemand
der meinung dass wir keine dynamische
entwicklung haben also das ist doch eine
realitätsverweigerung und deswegen meine
damen und herren werden wir uns dafür
einsetzen das sage ich auch ganz klar
dass diese epidemischen lagern auch
verlängert wird er bringt
entschuldigung herr bringt erlauben sie
eine zwischenfrage von herrn kubicki von
aus der spd
[Musik]
die zweite sache ist und das war es
einfach mal angucken müssen was wird
denn da vorgebracht was wir denn da
geformt hat da wird folgendes gefordert
in diesem gesetzentwurf das erste mal
haben es hier in länderpunkte geschlecht
werden den ländern wird flexibilität
genommen den ländern wären
handlungsoptionen genommen das geht doch
nicht meine damen und herren wir sind in
einer krise die länder müssen die
handlungsoptionen haben um entsprechend
gegen diese vor einer krise hervorgehen
zu können das zweite punkt ist und das
muss man ja auch sagen sie haben ja
viele sachen die wichtig sind sie sagen
gerade krankenhausfinanzierung herrscht
warum haben sie es nicht ins gesetz
eingebracht das wird jetzt irgendwo
nachgeliefert und ich meine man kann
auch von zukünftigen regierungsparteien
die in koalitionsverhandlungen sind in
dieser krise erwarten dass man sauber
liefert und ihr ist nicht sauber
geliefert worden meine damen und herren
wir
wollen das ganze neu bewertet da muss
man sagen es ist schön was sie da
aufgeschrieben haben es ist wirklich
dünn und es ist kommunikativ auch das
völlig falsche signal dadurch dass sie
die epidemische lagen von nationaler
tragweite aufheben sagen sie doch den
leuten es ist nicht mehr so schlimm es
ist nicht mehr so wichtig dass wir den
gesamten katalog im gegenteil wir müssen
den menschen sagen wir müssen noch
achtsamer sein wir müssen noch
vorsichtiger sagt wir müssen gut durch
diese krise durch kommen aber das geht
doch nicht wenn ich solche signale
setzen und deswegen
und deswegen liebe kolleginnen kollegen
haben sich ins zweigleisig fahren ja wir
sind nur konstruktive opposition ja und
herr scholz wir haben interesse daran
weil es im interesse des landes ist auch
ein vernünftiges ergebnis zu kriegen und
wenn sie nicht bereits und auch
vielleicht erklärt das gleich noch einer
von den rednerinnen und rednern die
epidemische lage zu verlängern dann
machen sie wenigstens ein vernünftiges
gesetz und ein vernünftiges gesetz zu
machen bedeutet dass die länder mehr
flexibilität brauchen und nicht mit
einem abschließenden katalog arbeiten
können denn dass wir ihnen die
handlungsoptionen für eine konsequente
krisenbekämpfung der norm entsprechend
nehmen dann schreiben sie auch alles in
dieses gesetz beim was notwendig ist
dann sagen sie uns was sie für eine
vorstellung kam wie zukünftig 2g und 3g
abgearbeitet werden sollte dann sagen
sie uns doch wie sie sich vorstellen
dass er konsequente schutz arbeitsplatz
da sein soll das sind doch die fragen
die wir uns stellen müssen damit wir
eine konsequente pandemie bekämpfung
kling kriegen und dass wir eine
konsequente pandemie bekämpfung brauchen
und sie haben es angesprochen
das sind wir diesen land schuldig und
das sind wir insbesondere liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen zwei gruppen in
diesem land schuldig wir haben viele
viele dinge richtig gemacht dass sie
nicht richtig gemacht haben wir haben im
letzten dezember und dem letzten januar
nicht die menschen in dem pflegeheim
schützen können und deswegen der
dringende appell alles dafür zu tun auch
an die länderseite dass das was im
dezember letzten jahres und im januar
diesen jahres passiert ist nicht normal
was wir und wir haben die zweite ganz
ganz ganz große schuld das ist die
schuld gegenüber den jungen menschen
dass die schuld gegenüber den menschen
diejenigen jungen menschen die nicht
kitas gehen konnten die nicht in die
schulen gehen konnten die nicht
studieren konnten die auf viel
verzichten mussten und deswegen weil
damen und herren sind wir es doch diesen
menschen schuldig dass wir alles dafür
tun dass wir schnell und gut durch diese
vierte welle kommen und dieses gesetz
was sie hier vorlegen das trägt nicht
dazu bei und deswegen gibt es da noch
was nach zu arbeiten vielen dank drive
brinkhaus der vorsitzende der
unions-fraktion
moniert dass die mutmaßlich zukünftige
ampelkoalition die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite aufheben will das
sei aus ordnungspolitischen gründen
falsch aber auch weil es das falsche
signal an die bevölkerung sei angesichts
steigender infektionszahlen katrin
göring eckardt ist die nächste rednerin
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen lieber herr brinkhaus
wir haben einen entwurf vorgelegt
nachdem klar ist dass die epidemische
lade von nationaler tragweite auslaufen
wird und wir mussten bis der entwurf
vorlegen weil eben nichts vorbereitet
worden ist von ihnen und der vorgänger
regierung und vom
bundesgesundheitsminister der in diesem
sommer gesagt hat 'jetzt können das
aufdecken
[Applaus]
wir haben eine
wir haben eine situation in der bei
weitem nicht genügend menschen in diesem
land hilft sind in der tat
wir haben einen gesundheitsminister der
noch amtiert der immer gesagt hat alle
haben ein angebot bekommen aber wo war
denn eigentlich das gespräch mit denen
die dieses angebot nicht wahrgenommen
haben das müssen wir jetzt nachholen das
müssen wir jetzt nacharbeiten bis zum
thema dritte impfung sie können sich
hier nicht draufstehen auf der
verantwortung herr brinkhaus das ist
schäbig und es ist verantwortungslos
mehr
eine dramatische lage wir haben
ansteckungszahlen die weit über dem
liegen was wir einfach hinnehmen könnte
wir müssen jetzt wir müssen jetzt darauf
reagieren mit maßnahmen die erstens
wirksam sind und zweitens rechtssicher
sind ich finde es nicht sinnvoll dass
wir uns hier hinstellen und sagen wir
machen mal maßnahmen die werden dann von
gerichten wieder gekippt das führt zu
neuer verunsicherung die können wir uns
nicht leisten meine damen und herren
und sehen sie heute
wenn sie heute in die krankenhäuser
schauen wenn sie in die pflegeheime
schauen ja auch in die schulen und kitas
dann sehen sie dort arbeiten wieder
menschen oder immer noch menschen am
limit das müssen wir ernst nehmen wir
müssen den krankenhäusern helfen wir
müssen klar sein beim schutz der
menschen in den pflegeheimen wir müssen
auch klar sein dabei das ist eben nicht
wieder die kinder und jugendlichen sein
können die zuerst zu hause bleiben
müssen deswegen eben auch viel mehr
schutz am arbeitsplatz übrigens auch
etwas was sie bisher nicht gemacht haben
hätte ich mir sehr gewünscht dass klar
als kinder
er bringt er aus am 22.10 hat die
ministerpräsidenten präsidentenkonferenz
den deutschen bundestag aufgerufen und
gebeten ein gesetz vorzulegen genau das
machen wir jetzt
nein die ministerpräsidentenkonferenz
hat gesagt sie brauchen einen rahmen und
diesen rahmen legen wir jetzt hier vor
und wir diskutieren ihnen das machen wir
nämlich auch anders als in der
vergangenheit wir sagen
dieser diskussion
und ins parlament und das ist nicht in
stein gemeißelt da muss man nicht
einfach dafür noch die hand heben
sondern dass es das was wir gemeinsam
hier diskutieren und besprechen mit
expertinnen und experten in der anhörung
mit den leuten in der praxis die
erfahrungen haben natürlich auch mit den
ministerpräsidenten und minister
präsidenten olaf scholz hat es
angekündigt zurecht hier muss mehr zu
einer gemeinsamen haltung zu einer
gemeinsamen lage einschätzung zu
gemeinsamem handeln kommen und dazu kann
ich sie nur aufrufen und indischen
billige parteipolitische aktion machen
und
zum beispiel anschaue wenn ich mir
anschaue worum es geht dann sage ich wir
sind solche rechtssicheren wirksamen
maßnahmen schuldig gerade denen den
krankenhäusern arbeiten in den
pflegeheimen in den schulen wir haben
eine inzidenz
bei denen die nicht geimpft sind die
ungefähr 20 mal höher ist als bei denen
die geimpft sind
wir haben eine wir haben eine situation
wo wir nicht einfach sagen können es ist
schon egal ob jemand geimpft ist das
werden gerichte nicht zu lassen und
deswegen müssen wir alle möglichen
maßnahmen und wir reden gerne weiter
darüber wie der katalog erweitert werden
kann über die masken pflicht über die
frage was machen wir am öpnv über die
frage wie grenzen wir veranstaltungen
natürlich brauchen wir zwei gehen das
ist eine der wirksamen maßnahmen die wir
jetzt machen können natürlich brauchen
wir das alles und wenn sie weitere
vorschläge haben dann reden wir darüber
sehr sehr her und ich finde wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass wir auch die
diskussion die gerade der ethikrat und
die leopoldina und auf den tisch gelegt
haben dass sie nämlich die frage stellen
wie ist es eigentlich mit einer
impfpflicht in einrichtungen die für
pflegende für andere wohlhabende gruppen
da sind ich finde diese diskussion
können wir uns nicht entziehen wir
müssen zu einem vernünftigen ergebnis
kommen aber eine impfung wird natürlich
erst in vielen vielen wochen und
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt
verlässliche test regimes für alle die
in dieser einrichtung gehen und deswegen
ist es notwendig dass die bürgerinnen
tests wieder da sind ich finde ein
wirklich großes versäumnis dass die
abgeschafft worden sind wir könnten es
besser und weiter sein wenn das nicht
der fall
deswegen verstehen dass das wir das was
wir jetzt tun was wir jetzt rasch tun
müssen was wir ihn selbstverständlich
mit den ländern besprechen das ist das
was für sicherheit in unserem land sorgt
alle hier machen sich bis auf sie da
ganz rechts alle hier machen sich glaube
ich große sorgen darum wie die nächsten
wochen gehen und natürlich hätten wir
uns alle mehr gewünscht wir könnten
irgendwie entspannt aufs weihnachtsfest
klicken das werden wir nicht tun können
und deswegen meinen aufruf lassen sie
uns mit den expertinnen diskutieren
lassen sie uns hier im parlament
diskutieren lassen sie uns aufhören
parteipolitisch hin und her miteinander
einer auseinandersetzung zu führen auf
dem rücken derjenigen die jetzt als
patientinnen und patienten auf intensiv
mit den pflegerinnen und pfleger lassen
sie uns keine diskussion führen auf dem
rücken derjenigen die die
schwierigkeiten in dieser partie nie in
dieser pandemie aushalten müssen
deswegen meine große bitte die debatte
sollte hier stattfinden wir sollten
dafür sorgen dass die menschen in
unserem land geschützt sind dass die
arbeitsplätze sicher sind dass die
pflegeheime sicher sind dass die kinder
das die jugendlichen weiter in kita und
schule gehen können wir sollten dafür
sorgen dass die intensivstation in
unserem land alle unterstützung bekommt
dafür dass sie diese so wichtige arbeit
auch ausreichend machen können wir
müssen dafür sorgen dass die lage in der
wir sind ernst genommen wird und dass
wirksame maßnahmen ergriffen werden
dafür stehen wir bereit dafür wollen wir
hier in diesem parlament diskutieren
dafür laden wir die ministerpräsidentin
die länder in diesem land ein und dazu
laden wir auch sie einmal und herren wir
haben die pandemische lage übrigens vier
mal hier mit abgestimmt und dann fünften
mal nicht jetzt sind sie am zug zu sagen
hier bin eben auch gemeinsam
verantwortung für dieses land das ist
das was der lage angemessen ist
herzlichen dank
katrin göring eckardt die vorsitzende
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen mit
einem appell gemeinsam und vor allem
auch im parlament nach lösungen zu
suchen gegen die pandemie
beziehungsweise um die pandemie
einzudämmen einer der ländervertreter
ist ja da heute nämlich bodo ramelow der
ministerpräsident von thüringen sitzt
auf der bank der das der bundesländer
nächster redner ist marco buschmann der
erste parlamentarische geschäftsführer
der fdp-fraktion die fraktion von spd
bündnis 90/die grünen und fdp legen
ihnen heute ein neues maßnahmenpaket zur
bekämpfung von corona bei es löst ein
altes maßnahmenpaket ab und der name
dieses alten maßnahmenpakets führt immer
wieder zu missverständnissen
manchmal hat man den eindruck dass diese
missverständnisse auch bewusst geschürt
werden manchmal hat man den eindruck es
wird so getan als ob nur weil das alte
maßnahmenpaket den namen epidemische
notlage von nationaler tragweite hält
das wenn man dieses alte maßnahmenpaket
abläuft irgend jemand behaupten würde
corona sei vorbei oder wir würden nicht
auch robuste maßnahmen diese gegen diese
krankheit
wollen und ich möchte an dieser stelle
mal eins sagen wir können hart in der
sache diskutieren über jedes einzelne
element aber lügen und fake news gehören
in den instrumentenkasten von diktatoren
und und populisten und die gehören nicht
in die debatte zwischen aufrechten
demokrat meine damen und herren
dass das alte maßnahmenpaket nicht so
bleiben konnte wie es wahr ist eine
frage der wahrhaftigkeit ich will sie
daran erinnern erst zu beginn des
letzten monats hat der bayerische
verfassungsgerichtshof die
ausgangssperren gekippt der bayerische
verfassungsgerichtshof hat gesagt dass
eine ausgangssperre selbst zu einem
zeitpunkt als es noch keinen impfstoff
in ausreichender menge gehabt nicht mehr
verhältnismäßigkeit war und deshalb wird
er auch heute wieder so urteilen dass
auch heute dieses instrument nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig wäre wer das ignoriert
ignoriert die anforderungen unseres
grundgesetzes und ich finde wir müssen
auch in der krise unser grundgesetz
respektieren damit wir das bleiben was
wir sind und was wir sein wollen nämlich
ein freiheitlicher rechtsstaat meine
damen und herren
und wir legen mit dem neuen
massnahmenpaket robuste maßnahmen für
die bekämpfung von corona vor wir
ermöglichen den ländern auf
rechtssichere grundlage all die
physikalischen infektions barrieren die
sie brauchen masken pflicht 3 gegen
abstands schlechten hygiene konzepte
auch welche die behördlich durchgesetzt
werden können das legen wir auf den
tisch und wir gehen über das hinaus was
in der vergangenheit pflicht war es wird
immer so getan als sei das nur ein - es
ist dort ein - wo es verfassungswidrig
wäre aber es ist dort ein meer wo wir
versagt haben und er bringt aus ich gebe
ihnen recht unser land hat versagt beim
schutz der älteren aber wenn sie mit dem
finger auf uns zeigen die wir in den
letzten jahren in der konstellation
nicht in verantwortung wahr müssen sie
mal erkennen dass ihr finger an der hand
mit dem finger auf den sie uns zeigen 3
finger auf sie zurück zeigen und das
macht ihren beitrag nicht so einen guten
beitrag in dieser debatte
hier werden für 3g sorgen und wir
liefern auch eine rechtsgrundlage für 2g
wir werden über test pflichten in den
alten und in den pflegeheim sprechen und
da hat unser land versagt es gab
bundesländer in denen die toten zu fast
90 prozent aus den alten und aus dem
pflegeheim kommen und wer da sagt dass
das instrumentarium dass wir jetzt
ablöse ein gutes war der verkennt die
realität er bringt aus und das müssen
sie sich ins stammbuch schreiben lassen
und deshalb nicht zum schluss
nachdem wir eine dinge klargestellt
haben noch zwei anmerkungen machen
erstens ich möchte mich ausdrücklich
beim bundesminister scholz dafür
bedanken dass er hier seine vorstellung
zur pandemie politik vorstellt denn sie
gehört in den deutschen bundestag sie
gehört in die herzkammer der demokratie
und des aufbaus richtig dass ihr zu tun
und 2
möchte ich sagen wenn jetzt ein
maßnahmenpaket vorlegt in einer der
umstrittensten fragen unseres landes dem
sowohl wolfgang kubicki wie auch karl
lauterbach
das prädikat erteilen dass man damit die
pandemie erfolgreich kämpfen kann dann
sollte es sich vielleicht der ein oder
andere den ruck geben dass renz weiß so
unterschiedlich denkende leute zu der
übereinstimmenden beurteilung kommen
dass wir ein geeignetes gutes und
rechtssicheres paket haben dann sollten
sich auch einige den ruck geben über
ihren parteipolitischen schatten sitzt
bei plötzlichen tag meine damen
marco buschmann verteidigt das was die
mutmaßlichen nächste koalition ihr
vorgelegt hat bezüglich der änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
und weiterer gesetzesänderung der
nächste redner ist sebastian münzenmaier
aus der afb fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren man höre und staune
nach dem vorliegenden gesetzentwurf soll
der deutsche bundestag feststellen dass
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite abgeschafft wird millionen von
menschen haben darauf gewartet denn man
hat ihnen versprochen dass mit dem ende
der epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite auch die
freiheitseinschränkung aufgehoben werden
freiheitseinschränkung die viele bürger
massiv getroffen haben die existenzen
vernichtet haben und die zu unzähligen
kollateralschäden geführt haben heute
könnte also für viele dieser menschen
ein tag der freiheit werden ein freedom
day gehen etliche andere länder bereits
gefeiert haben aber wenn man sich ihren
entwurf mal genauer anschaut stellt man
fest sie streichen zwar die epidemische
lage aber die maßnahmen sollen bleiben
die können jetzt ja nun sie fordern das
wortwörtlich so unabhängig davon
getroffen werden ob eine solche lage
überhaupt vorliegt und sie setzte im
vorliegenden gesetzesentwurf ja noch
einen drauf sie reden jetzt zwar munter
vom parlament und den diskussionen im
parlament aber erstens die nächste
kleine runde ist schon geplant werden es
gehört der minister präsent präsidenten
stammt ist nur wieder zusammentreten und
zweiten sie wollen verstetigen in diesem
gesetzentwurf das auf die entscheidung
des bundestages nicht mehr ankommt und
sie wollen die beteiligung der
landesparlamente auch noch aushebeln
damit degradiere nsi die herzkammern
unserer demokratie erneut zu statisten
und dieses undemokratische verhalten
wird von unserer fraktion abgelehnt
meine damen und herren
der vorliegende gesetzesentwurf und wir
haben es ganz deutlich hier vom
rednerpult von herrn scholz und frau
göring-eckardt gehört er wird zu zwei
dingen führen zu einer extremen
ausweitung der zweig regelung in
etlichen bundesländern und darauf
aufbauend zu einem weiteren massiven und
unanständigen druck auf menschen die
sich aus den unterschiedlichen gründen
nicht impfen lassen wollen wir als fdp
fraktion wir haben ein anderes ein
freiheitliches menschenbild im vergleich
zu ihnen allen für uns ist die impfung
eine persönliche entscheidung eines
jeden bürgers und diese entscheidung
muss freiwillig und ohne direkten oder
indirekten zwang erfolgen
und wundern sie sich denn nicht dass die
bürger da draußen in schlicht und
ergreifend nichts mehr glauben die stiko
zieht gerade die impfempfehlung für
unter 30-jährige mit dem impfstoff von
moderner aufgrund von nebenwirkungen
zurück für einige wohl zu spät meine
damen und herren die booster impfung
oder tritt impfung die von ihnen auch
heute wieder als weg aus der pandemie
propagiert wird die wird von der
fachwelt immer noch überhaupt nicht für
die gesamtbevölkerung empfohlen das
schlicht oder greifen und die einzigen
die es empfehlen sind die
selbsternannten virologen hier im
deutschen bundestag die meinen sie der
bevölkerung erklären was für sie gut und
richtig ist und isst aktuellste und
unsinnigste beispiel ihrer corona
politik der widersprüche ist die
sogenannte 2 gegen diese regel ist
schlicht und ergreifend sinnlos denn
sämtliche wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse haben uns gelehrt dass auch
geimpfte und gelesene ansteckend sein
können und diese menschen geimpft und
gelesene wegen sich also ohne test in
geschlossenen räumen und auf
großveranstaltungen in vermeintlicher
sicherheit und stecken andere personen
an während negativ getesteten menschen
die nachweisen können dass sie nicht
ansteckend sind draußen bleiben müssen
da geht es ihnen nur um impf druck denn
ginge es ihnen tatsächlich um eine
maßnahme des infektionsschutz dann
müssten sie wenn überhaupt alle
anwesenden ohne ansehen des imf oder
genesenen status testen meine damen und
herren oder um es mit den worten des
ehemaligen chef geologen der charité
professor krüger zu sagen 2g ist nicht
sicher aber unfrei und wir als fdp
fraktion wir lehnen auch weiterhin ihre
ideen der unfreiheit und des zwangs ab
und stehen stattdessen für eine rückkehr
zur freiheit zu eigenverantwortung und
zur vernunft basierter politik ich danke
ihnen für ihre aufmerksamkeit
stellen sie doch mit zwischenfragen denn
sie befragen
[Applaus]
nächste rednerin für die fraktion die
linke so seine fesche und susanne
fährstelle ist eine der
stellvertretenden fraktionsvorsitzenden
bei den linken
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen es
gibt natürlich heute nicht darum die
pandemie für beendet zu erklären dass
wir auch angesichts der dramatischen
infektionszahlen ziemlicher quatsch es
geht um die beendigung dieses
juristischen konstrukt mit dem begehren
verordnungsermächtigungen möglich ist
und damit muss schluss sein und das
finden wir auch gut
zu leben von spd fdp und grünen sie
betreiben schon auch ein bisschen
symbolpolitik weil natürlich müssen die
länder weiterhin maßnahmen ergreifen und
der amtierende bundesratspräsident sitzt
ja heute auch hier sie werden maßnahmen
ergreifen müssen um das
infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen
die symbolpolitik darf nicht dazu führen
dass wir den menschen aus vorgaukelt und
sie kollege buschmann sie haben ja
versprochen dass mit dem zwanzigsten
märz alle maßnahmen beendet sein werden
und seit monaten wird den menschen
erzählt wenn ihr dieses und jenes macht
dann ist die pandemie bald vorbei und
ich glaube die leute haben einfach den
kanal voll von diesen leeren
versprechungen
und deswegen sollten
allweiler daran halten im zweifelsfall
mal die klappe zu halten
es ist die vierte welle und es ist das
vierte mal dass die verantwortlichen
warten bis die welle über ihnen zusammen
schlägt und verantwortlich ist die noch
amtierende bundesregierung der noch
gesundheitsminister sparen und ich muss
schon sagen es war halt so ein bisschen
absurdes theater für mich herr scholz
ich weiß nicht waren sie in den letzten
jahren nicht in der
regierungsverantwortung sagen uns denn
die ganzen dinge nicht gemacht wie sie
vorgeschlagen haben und der
gerichtsentscheid
alles nicht gemacht was jetzt die ganze
zeit hier erzählt haben es ist einfach
sagen in eine gewesen was da passiert
ist
angefangen mit der abschaffung der
kostenlosen test die vierte welle die
war doch absehbar und auch geimpfte und
genießen können den virus weitergeben da
muss man doch mehr testen und nicht
weniger also es war doch eine absurde
entscheidung
oder wir zu niedrig ist
wo war denn ihre impfkampagne mit
aufsuchenden und mit niedrigschwelligen
angeboten andere länder zeigen dass es
deutlich besser geht und dann die
fehlende booster impfung für die über 60
jährigen und die wilde rabe in gruppen
die müssten doch alle schönen drittes
mal geimpft sein die erfahrungen aus
israel die zeigen doch dass der
impfschutz nachlässt der stadt zu
reagieren haben sie auch noch die elf
zentren abgeschafft jetzt kommen die
hausärzte nicht hinterher bekämpfen das
ist wirklich unfassbar
und was was haben sie eigentlich getan
in all der zeit um den pflegenotstand
wenigstens zu ländern wenigstens zu
lindern es stehen jetzt noch weniger
intensiv betten zur verfügung als anfang
des jahres weg legen und dann der
kollegen in der pflege so überlastet
sind dass sie weiterhin aus dem beruf
flüchten und ich wünsche an der stelle
den kolleginnen und kollegen im
öffentlichen dienst in den ländern die
jetzt im streik sind viel
durchhaltevermögen und viel erfolg denn
eure arbeit ist mehr wert
die beamten wurden sind jetzt
sofortmaßnahmen die rückkehr zu den
kostenlosen tests ist schon beschlossen
ist es auch gut so eine lückenlose
testpflicht unabhängig vom impfstatus
insbesondere in pflegeeinrichtungen
wir dürfen die menschen nicht erneut
einsperren und auch die arbeitgeber
müssen beim arbeitsschutz in die pflicht
genommen werden auch 3g max sinn machen
aber unter einhaltung der
datenschutzrechtlichen vorschriften es
kann nicht sein dass der arbeitgeber den
impfstatus erträgt da sind wir an der
seite der gewerkschaften
und im übrigen jetzt selbstverständlich
um impfen impfen aber eines ist auch
klar und damit nicht dann auch am ende
wir brauchen investitionen ins
gesundheitswesen in kitas in schulen in
die öffentliche daseinsvorsorge
insgesamt denn eine gesellschaft die nur
auf profit getrimmt ist wird immer
pandemie anfällig bleiben vielen dank
die stellvertretende vorsitzende der
linksfraktion susanne fesche war dass
sie in einer debatte des bundestages zum
infektionsschutzgesetz beziehungsweise
den änderungen dazu und da wird der
nächste redner dirk wiese sein
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
spd-fraktion und einer von denen die in
den vergangenen tagen und wochen mit
federführend waren für seine fraktion an
diesem bei diesem gesetzentwurf
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren ich glaube es
ist ein wichtiges signal dass hier am
heutigen tag der gesetzentwurf der
möglichen zukünftigen ampel koalitionäre
eingebracht wird ist zeigt mit diesem
gesetzentwurf dass wir verantwortung
übernehmen in einer nicht einfachen
situation dass wir verantwortung
übernehmen auch über den 25 10 11 hinaus
vor allem rechtssichere maßnahmen auf
den weg zu bringen rechtssichere
maßnahmen auf den weg zu bringen die
nicht vor einem gericht scheitern die
nicht wieder infrage gestellt werden die
nicht von heute auf morgen nachgebessert
werden sondern die den ländern einen
instrumentenkasten in die hand geben auf
diese nicht einfache situation zu
reagieren zu antworten und diese
möglichkeit geben wir ihnen mit diesem
gesetzentwurf den wir heute auf den weg
bringen
möchte an dieser stelle auch die
möglichkeit nutzen einmal denjenigen
danke zu sagen die jetzt gerade in
dieser schwierigen situation in den
krankenhäusern diejenigen pflegen und
sich um die kümmern die schweren
verläufen ausgesetzt sind diese
pflegerinnen und pfleger in den
krankenhäusern die ärztinnen und ärzte
sie leisten seit beginn dieser pandemie
eine unglaubliche arbeit ja es sind
schwierige arbeitsbedingungen ja es ist
herausfordernd wir wissen dass sie ist
einiges zu tun aber mein großer respekt
für das was dort wieder täglich
geleistete gerade jetzt in der situation
wo es in einigen krankenhäusern auch
schwieriger wird
ich kann auch die sorgen verstehen der
vielen eltern die unsicher sind momentan
gerade aufgrund der situation dass die
schülerinnen und schüler gerade bis zur
vollendung des ersten lebensjahres auch
noch nicht geimpft werden können dass
man sich gedanken macht dass man sorgen
machen wenn der tägliche gang in die
schule letztendlich auch an steht aber
auch hier ist es wichtig dass wir als
ampel und zukünftige ampel koalitionäre
maßnahmen auf den weg bringen auflagen
gerade für gemeinschaftseinrichtungen
auch möglich machen wollen und weiter
möglich machen sagt möglich sein sollen
und ich muss auch ganz klar sagen bin
manchmal etwas überrascht dass das eine
oder andere bundesland in dieser
situation die einfache maßnahme dieser
zielgerichtet ist eine masken pflicht an
schulen zu haben vielleicht etwas
vorschnell schon aufgehoben hat also
hier wünschte ich mir gerade diese
möglichkeiten die es jetzt per gesetz
gibt und die es zukünftig auch geben
auch anzuwenden das sind einfache
schutzmaßnahmen die können helfen und
die sollte man nicht vorschnell aufhören
ich bin auch oder stolz dankbar dafür
dass er das was wir vorhaben und das wo
es hingehen soll auch hier zuerst im
deutschen bundestag heute auch erläutert
hat und olaf scholz hat es angesprochen
das entscheidende ist dass wir bei den
impfungen vorankommen dass wir einen
zahn zulegen das wir gerade auch mit
praktikern ins gespräch kommen was gibt
es eigentlich auch noch für kreative
lösungen um diejenigen zu erreichen die
noch nicht den entschluss letztendlich
gefasst haben darum ist es auch ein
signal dass wir auch als zukünftige
ampelkoalition ehre ein praktiker
pendelt auf den weg bringen was morgen
im deutschen bundestag stattfinden wird
wenn wir noch einmal die expertise der
vielen einholen wollen die täglich
draußen unterwegs sind die durch
kreative lösungen in einigen regionen zu
hohen impfquoten kommen und das muss
noch mal ein ziel sein das mit in dieses
laufende verfahren mit einfließen zu
lassen
wir bringen jetzt in diesem entwurf
zielgerichtete maßnahmen auf den weg ja
auch mit änderungsanträgen eine
verpflichtende testpflicht 3g am
arbeitsplatz 2g 3g auch in der
ermöglichung für die bundesländer und
ich will das mal ganz deutlich sagen es
ist ja auch nicht so dass die länder
nichts gemacht haben in der letzten zeit
wir hatten eine sehr wichtige
gesundheitsministerkonferenz der länder
die stadt gefunden hat wo wichtige
beschlüsse gefasst worden sind von den
ländern an die bundesregierung und diese
werden wir jetzt auch im laufenden
gesetzgebungsverfahren mit aufnehmen mit
einfließen lassen und hier auch an der
ein oder anderen stelle wo es notwendig
ist wo es zu mehr rechtssicherheit führt
auch nach steuern und das kann ich auch
zu sichern
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen per
brinkhaus ich muss auf das eine oder
andere aber noch einmal ganz kurz
eingehen was sie gerade hier gesagt
haben ich will ja nicht verhehlen dass
es bei der letzten verlängerung der
epidemischen lage nicht so gewesen ist
dass sie als fraktion geschlossen
abgestimmt haben das muss man vielleicht
hier an dem punkt noch einmal erwähnen
und das ist auch innerhalb ihrer
fraktion über die frage der epidemischen
lage auch debatten gegeben hat was sie
aber heute nicht gemacht haben wir und
das können sie im laufenden verfahren
gerne noch nach steuern sie haben gesagt
das müsste möglich gemacht werden das
müsste möglich gemacht haben sie haben
keinen konkreten vorschlag gemacht sagen
sie uns bitte konkret was halten sie im
verfahren für zielführend was brauchen
sie noch an konkreten master wir schauen
uns das annehmen dass mit auf aber ich
muss schon sagen das sage ich auch sehr
deutlich ich weiß manchmal nicht was ich
an berlin und münchen auf der a 9
stattfindet ich bin markus söder dankbar
dass er bis zum 26 90 täglich geäußert
hat das hat uns geholfen das hat diese
neue konstellation mit möglich macht
aber ganz offen gesprochen das was
markus söder seit dem 26
das ist kein verantwortbares handeln
eines ministerpräsident er zeit gilt die
epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite sie gilt noch er könnte
handelt er tut es nicht er redet wie
aber macht vor ort nicht nicht mal zweig
in seinem eigenen kabinett vielen dank
der wiese am ende seiner rede noch mal
mit kritik an bayerns ministerpräsident
markus söder und davor hatte eingeräumt
dass das eine und andere oder der der
eine und andere punkt bei dem
gesetzentwurf der mutmaßlich zukünftigen
ampelkoalition zum
infektionsschutzgesetz nochmal
präzisierte werden muss das kann
beispielsweise in der anhörung am
kommenden montag passieren und jetzt
aber alexander dobrindt vorsitzende der
csu landesgruppe
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das
holz sie haben hier gesagt wir müssen
weiter vorsichtig sein dazu hätten sie
heute jede chance gehabt und zwar mit
einem klaren bekenntnis dass sie die
epidemische lage weiter verlängern
wollen die hospitalisierung steigt das
infektionsgeschehen explodiert die
dritte impfung muss erst an fahrt
gewinnen die risiken steigen und sie
schrauben dem instrumentenkasten runter
das kann nicht gut den ja scholz
sie verlassen geradezu das team vorsicht
und sie gehen ins team versucht es mal
das reicht aber nicht für ihre neue
verantwortung und und diese entsprechend
nachzukommen gerade im august herr
scholz da haben sie sich noch für die
verlängerung der epidemischen lage
ausgesprochen heute bei mehr kranken bei
mehr infizierten bei mehrbelastung der k
beenden sie politisch die epidemische
lage das ist schlichtweg eine falsche
entscheidung an dieser stelle
sie werben hier
eindrucksvoll für das impfen aus meiner
sicht vollkommen zu recht aber sie geben
komplett andere signale wenn sie heute
die epidemische lage beenden wollen wie
soll das in der öffentlichkeit
eigentlich ankommen wie wollen sie
menschen davon überzeugen sich impfen zu
lassen wenn sie das signal geben es wird
schon irgendwie werden die epidemische
lage muss nicht verlängert werden es
kommt schon wieder alles irgendwie in
ordnung das reicht nicht als signal um
die impfbereitschaft zu erhöhen
was sie aber tun
sie werden als ampel sicher unser
gesundheitswesen vor einer
belastungsprobe stellen wir haben jetzt
schon regionen in deutschland mit einer
inzidenz von über 1000 weiter steigend
die intensivbetten sind belegt
in verschiedensten regionen in
deutschland auch in bayern auch in
sachsen auch in anderen ländern wird
genau das anstehen und beim besten
willen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
ich verstehe diese hämische zwischenrufe
an dieser stelle überhaupt nicht es geht
um infizierte es geht um kranke menschen
es geht um belastungen der krankenhäuser
es geht um eine situation die sich
weiter verschärft oder diesen
jugendlichen zwischen
beim besten willen spaß das zeigt dass
die ziele sind auch nicht
regierungsfähig bei den damen und herren
man muss kein hellseher sein um zu sehen
dass in den nächsten tagen oder wochen
ist zu einer belastung des
gesundheitswesens führen kann deswegen
ist es falsch den instrumentenkasten an
dieser stelle zu reduzieren es ist
schlichtweg ein fehler und sehr geehrter
herr buschmann ich habe ihre rede sehr
genau zugehört
ich muss sagen auf ihrer webseite kann
man aktuell nachlesen ich zitiere daraus
eine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems sei nicht mehr zu
erwarten was für eine grandiose
fehleinschätzung
und herr buschmann sie sagen hier am
pult gerade vorhin
wir gehen über die bisherigen maßnahmen
hinaus ich darf sie aus ihrer webseite
aus ihrer webseite herr buschmann
zitieren dort sagen sie aktuell
nachlesbar
die fraktionen wollen daher den ländern
nur noch befristet niederschwellige und
wenig eingriffs intensive maßnahme bis
zum frühjahr
2022 ermöglichen sie reduzieren die
maßnahmen tier steht die wahrheit auf
ihrer website und nicht in jeder rede im
deutschen bundestag
göring eckardt sie haben hier gesagt wir
können das uns jetzt nicht leisten dass
maßnahmen von gerichten gekippt werden
sie haben über rechtssicherheit
gesprochen ich darf sie an dieser stelle
fragen was ist rechtssicherer wenn der
deutsche bundestag die epidemische lage
feststellt und weiter verlängert oder ob
sie ein halbherziges gesetz auf den weg
bringe leute daran gern
und er schaut sie haben hierzu zweig
geworben sie haben gesagt sie schaffen
jetzt die maßnahme die maßnahmen dafür
gibt es übrigens in der epidemischen
lage und nicht erst durch ihr gesetz sie
haben dafür geworben ich kann ihn an der
stelle einfach nur sagen dann nehmen sie
auch ihre verantwortung wahr und kommen
sie mit ländern und bund zu einer
gemeinsamen lösung sie können zweig in
deutschland durchsetzen sie haben die
entscheidung dafür mit zutreffen ziehen
können druck machen und sie können alle
länder mit ins boot nehmen dazu gehört
aber die bereitschaft dass man mit bund
und ländern über die aktuelle lage fair
und offen spricht gemeinsamen
entscheidungen trifft kommen sie dieser
verantwortung nach sie haben sie jetzt
nehmen sie auch an dankeschön
alexander dobrindt vorsitzende der csu
landesgruppe ist höher und erkennbar
schon mal in der opposition angekommen
heftige kritik an dem gesetzentwurf der
zukünftigen
ampelkoalition und hier gehts weiter mit
maria klein schmeink auch
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
und auch sie hat an diesem gesetzentwurf
maßgeblich mitgearbeitet
[Applaus]
präsidentin lieber herr dobrindt ich
muss sagen sie haben sich gerade
wirklich verstiegen dieser werdenden
ampel vorzuwerfen sie würde das
gesundheitswesen schädigen und
gleichzeitig eine situation verantworten
zu müssen in bayern wo sie die neue
höchst betroffenen landkreise bundesweit
stellen wo sie ernsthaft vor der
situation stehen dass eine überlastung
ihrer krankenhäuser
in
intensivstationen und der
beschäftigten in diesen in
intensivstationen zu verantworten haben
das ist ihre verantwortung und es ist
unverschämt an dieser stelle all
diejenigen die sich hier wirklich
bemühen lösungen zu finden so was
vorzuwerfen das ist unverantwortlich
herr brinkhaus ich meine wir haben in
den letzten zwei jahren versucht
gemeinsam dafür zu sorgen dass wir als
bundestag verantwortung übernehmen dass
wir schauen dass wir diese sehr sehr
schwierige situation tatsächlich meister
und dass wir dem gerecht werden was
insbesondere all denjenigen die entweder
betroffen sind die eltern sind die viel
viel haben tragen müssen kinder und
jugendliche die viel viel haben tragen
müssen und den vielen betroffenen und
schwer erkranken oder auch verstorbenen
menschen im hohen alter da wir uns um
verantwortung bemüht und sie haben heute
hier eine rede gehalten die zeigt dass
sie nicht auf dem weg einer
konstruktiven opposition sind mit uns
gemeinsam konstruktiv nach lösungen
suchen sondern dass sie den billigen und
sehr offene opportunistischen die
anklage suchen und nicht mit uns
gemeinsam jetzt geht es darum die
epidemische lagern hat keine dieser
entwicklung die wir jetzt sehen
irgendwie aufhalten können sie haben
eben gerade nicht die maßnahmen
vorgelegt die wir jetzt brauchen und das
tun wir mit dem gesetz jetzt wir
schaffen zusätzliche möglichkeiten zu
leben
bisher im infektionsschutzgesetz
vorgesehen war wir schaffen den besseren
schutz der beratenden in den
einrichtungen indem wir zusätzliche test
pflichten für festlegen das schaffen
insgesamt einen besseren schutz indem
wir insbesondere auch dafür sorgen dass
am arbeitsplatz das im bereich der
arbeitswelt wir zusätzliche
schutzmöglichkeiten haben zusätzliche
pflichten des testens haben und wir
werden dafür sorgen dass wir all die
maßnahmen die wir jetzt vorgelegt haben
im anhörungsverfahren noch einmal auf
den prüfstand stellen schauen ob wir
nachsteuern müssen und wir haben uns als
werden der koalition versprochen dass
wir nach steuern immer da wo es
notwendig ist dass wir die notwendige
maßnahmen schaffen und für
handlungsfähigkeit sorgen und insgesamt
zur verantwortung gehört impfen das eben
voranzubringen das ist der schlüssel den
wir brauchen wir müssen die ungeimpften
erwachsenen erreichen dringend wir
müssen viel viel schneller werden bei
dem booster impfung bei den
auffrischungsimpfungen damit wir
sicherstellen können dass in den
nächsten wochen die intensivstation
nicht volllaufen grad mit denjenigen die
als ältere den immunschutz verlieren das
ist das was wir jetzt tun müssen und
gemeinschaftlich müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass alle an einem strang ziehen sonst
wird es uns nicht gelingen gut durch
diesen winter zu kommen und wir legen
mit diesem gesetz viele maßnahmen vor
mit denen wir weiter nach steuern können
machen sie mit tragen sie mit uns eine
offene diskussion dazu aus was wir tun
müssen was wir anpacken können wir wir
sind gespannt was sie an weiteren
vorschlägen ein in die diskussion wir
jedenfalls sind in der offenen
diskussion nehmen alle anregungen aus
dem von aus der anhörung auf so werden
wir vorgehen und damit wären wir auch
eine bessere situation schaffen danke
maria klein schmeink aus der fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen und ihr wird in
dieser debatte zum
infektionsschutzgesetz beziehungsweise
dessen änderung aber auch weiterer
gesetze die in der folge der aufhebung
der epidemischen lage nationaler
tragweite nötig werden folgen christine
aschenberg-dugnus aus der fdp-fraktion
gesundheitspolitikerin
eine änderung des
infektionsschutzgesetzes
ist längst überfällig denn wir benötigen
rechtssicherheit
in der korona krise und dieses parlament
muss daran beteiligt so ein meine damen
und herren wir haben uns gemeinsam mit
spd und grünen zusammen gesetzt um diese
lösungen zu erarbeiten und diese
lösungen werden jetzt ja da werden sich
die kolleginnen und kollegen von der
cdu/csu verwundert die augen reiben in
einem geordneten gesetzgebungsverfahren
auf den weg gebracht meine damen und
herren
heute die erste in einer woche die
zweite und dritte lesung es wird eine
anhörung geben selbstverständlich mit
verbesserungsvorschlägen egal wo sie
herkommen werden wir offen und
transparent umgehen kurzum meine damen
und herren es findet die von uns seit
langer zeit geforderte
parlamentarisierung stadt und das ist
gut so
weil der der amazonas parlament ist
handlungsfähig selbst in zeiten einer
lediglich
geschäftsführenden regierung wir zeigen
dass wir in der lage sind zügig zu
reagieren tja und jetzt geht es los es
kommen natürlich sofort
vorwürfe der untätigkeit der
unzureichenden mittel im
infektionsschutzgesetz
verbrät haus hat es gesagt herr dobrindt
hat es gesagt und natürlich kommen die
lautesten stimmen von einem vorsitzenden
einer regionalpartei der sich eigentlich
nur darüber ärgert kurz vor der
landtagswahl dass er sich nicht mehr
hinter dem bund verstecken kann meine
damen und herren
und ich sage hier ganz deutlich
nach die maßnahmen zu schreien die dann
wieder von den gerichten aufgehoben
werden nehmen sie sich doch einfach mal
ein beispiel im süden deutschlands an
meinem heimatland schleswig holstein im
quote der über 60-jährigen
90% impfquote der 12 bis 17 jährigen
57%
booster impfungen in den heimen im
august bereits vorbereitet und seit
september finden diese statt einen
schönen gruß mal aus dem nur schönen
norden in den süden der großartig
pressekonferenzen zu geben sollte man
auch einfach handeln
und um es an dieser stelle noch einmal
ganz deutlich zu sagen
mit dem auslaufen der epidemischen
notlage mit der nichtverlängerung würden
natürlich nicht festgestellt dass coruna
vorbei ist ich glaube die menschen
unsere bevölkerung ist intelligenter als
die cdu csu glaubt die wissen nämlich
können die lage sehr gut einschätzen
meine damen und herren und dafür braucht
es nicht der verlängerung der
epidemischen lage wir wollen mit unserem
vorgelegten gesetz den ländern die
möglichkeit geben auf gesetzlicher
grundlage die angemessenen maßnahmen die
notwendig sind weiter zu führen wir
werden und vor allem das jetzt durch das
auslaufen der epidemischen lage den
ländern maßnahmen entzogen würden das
stimmt auf jeden fall nicht meine damen
und herren und eines möchte ich an
dieser stelle auch noch mal ganz
deutlich sagen es muss jetzt unser aller
oberste priorität sein die wohl mehr
abel in gruppen zu schützen
denn das vergangene jahr darf sich nicht
wiederholen und ich glaube da sind wir
uns doch alle einig
konkreten müssen wir wie in schleswig
holstein die booster impfungen
voranbringen wir müssen jeden der eine
alten und pflegeeinrichtung eine
einrichtung für menschen mit behinderung
betritt jeder muss getestet werden um
diese gruppen weiterhin gut zu schützen
wie reagieren außerdem indem wir die
dreiwöchige regel am arbeitsplatz
einführen die wieder einführung
kostenfreier test ganz wichtig wir
wollen die krankenhäuser finanziell
besser ausstatten und wir bringen einen
runden tisch um die menschen zu
erreichen die wir bisher bei den
impfungen noch nicht erreicht haben das
sind konkrete maßnahmen und das ist mehr
als die bundesregierung die letzte
überhaupt auf den weg gebracht habe
meine damen und herren das sind
maßnahmen um menschenleben zu retten und
das sind konkrete maßnahmen die wir
jetzt brauchen wir nehmen die lage sehr
ernst und ich freue mich auf das
verfahren auf die anhörung wir werden
gute maßnahmen auf den weg bringen ganz
herzlichen dank
sagt christine aschenberg-dugnus aus der
fdp fraktion in der letzten
legislaturperiode war die
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin ob sie
dieser legislaturperiode wieder in diese
position kommt ist noch offen jetzt aber
jörg schneider afd
die neue bundesregierung möchte die
pandemische lage bin dann was wird sich
für die menschen ändern nichts zumindest
nicht zum besser
wir haben nämlich die wenn doch weiter
von ihnen hören lassen sie sich impfen
tragen sie im bus eine maske dann wird
alles gut nur wir wissen doch es wird
damit nicht alles gut es funktioniert
mich denn die alte und die neue
bundesregierung sehr meines nicht
verstanden unser problem ist nicht der
30-jährige ungeimpfte unser problem ist
der 30-jährige geimpfte der seinen
80-jährigen oper besucht in an geimpft
oder sorglosigkeit lassen sich beide
nicht testen enkel infiziert in opa opa
landet auf der intensivstation
das kriegen sie vielleicht den begriff
in alten- und pflegeheim aber dort oper
noch in der eigenen wohnung wohnt da
bräuchten sie eigentlich
eigenverantwortung nur sie neben den
menschen die freiheit freiheit ist aber
die grundlage dafür dass menschen eigen
verantwortung entwickeln keine freiheit
keine eigenverantwortung wir werden
corona so nicht in den griff bekommen
meine damen und herren
sie setzen stattdessen weiter auf
freiheitsbeschränkungen auf 3 gegen wir
haben doch hier im bundestag gesehen es
funktioniert nicht unsere kunst die
sitzung 700 abgeordneten tag ihr
zusammen
und einer war infiziert rechnen sie das
mal auf eine wahren incidents hoch das
ist eine wochen- incidents von 1000
meine damen und herren der der
abgeordnete hatte gott sei dank an
milden verlauf aber das zeigt uns doch
zwei dinge erstens eine inzidenz von
1000 ist nicht zwingend eine katastrophe
und zweitens sie werden eine inzidenz
von 1000 nicht mit drei gegnern meine
damen und herren
verhindern wollen sie stattdessen das
gefälschte impfpässe verwendet werden
gibt das problem dabei ist es ist so
fürchterlich einfach einen impfpass zu
fälschen und dann gehen sie damit zur
apotheke lassen sich das ding
digitalisieren
damit es an der alle spuren verwischt
der apotheker naja der kriegt dafür ein
paar euro für die paar euro wird er in
der regel nicht zum privat ermittlern
und ich frage sie warum sie nicht dafür
dass imbisse fälschungssicher werden
meine damen und herren
diese neue regierung
sie wird nichts ändern die menschen
werden sich in angehender sorglosigkeit
weiterhin infizieren trotz 3g und auch
trotz zweige werden wir ruhe instanzen
haben das hält den panik level hoch und
wir werden auch weiterhin gefälschte
impfpässe erleben wenn sie etwas ändern
wollen dann folgen sie dem beispiel von
frank von großbritannien folgen sie dem
beispiel von dänemark dem sie den
menschen ihre freiheit zurück geben sie
den menschen die basis wieder
eigenverantwortung zu entwickeln denn
auf diese art und weise können wir
tatsächlich diese pandemie bekämpfen ich
denke mir der fünfundzwanzigster
november das ist ein gutes datum ein
gutes daten und für einen deutschen tag
der freiheit ich danke ihnen
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr jan marco luczak und er ist
rechtspolitiker seiner fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen ich möchte noch
gerne zurückkommen auf den anfang
unserer debatte
bundesminister scholz hat sich hier als
zukünftiger kanzler hingestellt und
gesagt das virus ist nicht weg und die
lage ist nicht gut oder hat recht damit
und das wird auch
besorgniserregende weise durch die
zahlen die wir heute auch wieder hören
deutlich gemacht wir haben 50.000 neu
infekt zügen am tag das ist der höchste
wert den wir in der pandemie jemals
gehabt haben yamaha unglaublich hohe
dynamik das sind 50 prozent mehr
neuinfektionen gegenüber der vorwoche
die inzidenz liegt bei 249 in drei
wochen hat sich das fast verdreifacht
die anzahl von toten nimmt zu die
intensivbetten sind mittlerweile so
ausgelastet dass wichtige operationen
verschoben werden müssen dass sie nicht
durchgeführt werden müssen hier
erscheint und dann sagen sie wenn sie so
etwas sagen das virus ist nicht weg die
lage ist nicht gut dann brauchen sie
doch nicht allen ernstes sagen dass die
voraussetzung für die epidemische lage
die wir hier im bundestag miteinander
geschlossen als es die nicht mehr
vorliegen das ist doch nicht ernst meine
damen und herren und ich will ihnen
sagen ich will ihnen sagen wieso die das
sagen sie haben offensichtlich angst vor
der fdp genauso wie im sollen die rohs
papier haben sie sich hier über den
tisch ziehen lassen von einem falschen
freiheitsverständnis ich sage ihnen
etwas freiheit bedeutet auch immer
verantwortung und verantwortung bedeutet
an dieser stelle auch unbequeme
entscheidungen treffen zu müssen und
natürlich ist die epidemische lage eine
unbequeme entscheidung ich sage aber
wenn es notwendig ist um den schutz der
gesundheit der menschen zu gewährleisten
dann muss man auch den mut haben zu
dieser unter geben entscheidung lampe
hat offensichtlich nicht diesen gut
meinen da mithalten
und darunter ich mich da schon ein
bisschen dass die spd und die grünen
sich ganz offensichtlich in die
mithaftung nehmen das und ich sehe den
kollegen lauter macht wer durch jede
talkshow klingelt und als rosa dort
auftritt sagt was wir alles brauchen sie
sind das gesicht offensichtlich der spd
für die korona bekämpfung aber sie haben
offensichtlich 0 durchsetzungskraft in
ihrer eigenen fraktion weil von den
dingen die sie öffentlich in talkshows
sagen findet sich in diesem
gesetzentwurf kein einziges mal damen
und herren wir
haben aktuell eine rechtssichere
grundlage wir haben eine bewährte
rechtsgrundlage mit dem 28 der ausbau
auf der led mission grundlage und so
durch wollen sie das jetzt ersetzen
durch einen maßnahmenkatalog der in
keiner weise ausreichend ist der in
keiner weise entschlossen und zielgenau
gewährleistet dass wir effizient gegen
korona vorgehen können wir sind uns doch
alle einig wir brauchen flächendeckend
zwar geht ja wo ist denn die
rechtsgrundlage für eine konkrete rechts
sich dieser bundeseinheitliche regelung
wo ist denn die rechtsgrundlage für
verpflichtende testen in
gemeinschaftseinrichtungen wo ist denn
die rechtsgrundlage für eine allgemeine
das auskunftsrecht des arbeitgebers all
das findet sich nicht in ihrem
gesetzentwurf das ist ein scheitern mit
ansage was sie hier machen meine damen
und herren von der antl und
das gleiche gilt für das thema fälschung
von ausweisen
die bedeutung von impfen ausweisen hat
in der pandemie enorm zugenommen das ist
für den schutz der gesundheit für die
abschätzung von infektionsrisiken und
für das vertrauen in die pandemie
bekämpfung eminent wichtig dass wir uns
verlassen können dass impfnachweis
richtig rechtssicher und valide sind und
deswegen sagen wir also nun ganz klar
wer impfausweise fälschte er muss hart
bestraft werden da gibt es kein vertun
an dieser stelle und das ist mord nach
dem momentanen gesetzeslage nicht
gewährleistet strafbarkeitslücken es
gibt ungerechtfertigter privilegierung
an der stelle deswegen haben wir als
union einen gesetzentwurf vorgelegt der
diese strafbarkeitslücken schließt wir
haben die ampel jetzt damit aus unserer
energie gerissen damit selbst ein
gesetzentwurf vorgelegt nachdem das
bundesjustizministerium über monate sich
geweigert hat einen solchen
entsprechenden gesetzentwurf vorzulegen
da sieht man wieder wir machen eine
konstruktive oppositionspolitik und
opposition wird auch an dieser stelle
meine damen und herren
[Applaus]
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage von
herrn lautermann selbstverständlich
jährigen bemerkung
vielen dank
sie haben recht zweig wäre das was jetzt
notwendig wäre aber ich möchte dich
fragen also die jetzige rechtslage geht
ja noch die epidemische lage gilt er
noch das heißt bundesweit wäre zweig
durch die noch amtierende regierung ein
fehler gewesen und demnächst wenn also
die neue regelung gilt es ist durch
jedes bundesland einführbar das heißt
zweig ist jetzt ein für war
deutschlandweit und es ist demnächst ein
für bar für jedes bundesland stingl
nicht durch die talkshow sondern werde
eingeladen und ich werde ich
empfehle ich empfehle dort ich empfehle
ich empfehle dort ich empfehle dort
flächendeckend die 2g regelungen die wir
auch konto die wir auch kontrollieren
müssten meine frage ist jetzt die
folgende wie sie erwecken sie hier den
falschen eindruck als wären wir zwar
nicht bundesweit und in den einzelnen
ländern längst machen können also wieso
erwecken sie diesen falschen eindruck
lieber herr kollege lauterbach also
zunächst einmal ist mir der unterschied
zwischen durch die talkshows tingeln und
dort eingeladen werden nicht sehr
geläufig ich glaube es kommt im ergebnis
auf das gleiche raus sie haben mit ihrer
frage ja eigentlich genau das deutlich
gemacht sie haben doch gerade genauer
gesagt in der tat können wir
bundeseinheitlich das festlegen nach dem
was sie uns jetzt hier mit diesem
gesetzentwurf vorlegen würde es eben
nicht mehr möglich sein dass
bundeseinheitlich besten unseren jedes
land muss es selber machen und da können
sie doch nicht abstreiten dass das ein -
ist dass es ein weniger es gegenüber dem
gesetz des zustand den wir jetzt aktuell
haben und deswegen ist all das was sich
hier um die zone von dante vortragen
dass man hier mehr machen können das ist
eben teil - das stimmt nicht wenn man
sich die rechtsgrundlagen genauer
anschaute sie jetzt vorgeschlagen haben
das was sie hier in der debatte
vortragen dass man das noch machen will
dass man noch viele andere maßnahmen im
parlamentarischen verfahren machen
möchte wieso haben sie es denn nicht
leid in den gesetzentwurf
reingeschrieben das ist eine
mogelpackung sie machen und damit lernen
wie sie als union nicht durchkommen
lassen mit dieser falschen argumentation
die sie hervorbringen
sie haben noch einen letzten schlusssatz
ein letzter schluss möchte ich noch
zudem ausweisen
verbinden der gesetzentwurf den die
ampel und hier vorgelegt hat der ist
absolut unzureichend die
strafbarkeitslücken die aktuell
existieren werden damit nicht
zweifelsfrei geschlossen die nicht
gerechtfertigten prämiierung die es gibt
im rechtszustand werden ebenfalls nicht
aufgenommen ich kann nur ein beispiel
sagt wieso soll zum beispiel ein arzt
der korona leugnet und einem impfpass
falsch ausstellt wieso sollte er
eigentlich geringer bestraft werden als
jemand der ohne arzt zu sein ein
impfausweis fest das ist doch ein
widerspruch wenn jemand seine stellung
als arzt missbraucht muss dennoch vater
bestraft werden als irgendjemand und das
war damen und herren dieser
ungerechtfertigten differenzierung in
ihrem gesetzentwurf die sind nicht
überzeugungen und deswegen bitte ich um
zustimmung für unseren gesetzentwurf er
ist besser als das was die ampel uns
hier vorgelegt hat vielen dank jan marco
luczak für die unionsfraktion und nach
einem kleineren gefecht mit karl
lauterbach aus der spd-fraktion hier ist
immer wieder über von verantwortung die
rede zwischen bund bundestag und den
bundesländern und das gibt mir noch mal
die gelegenheit zu verweisen auf die
vertreter auf der bundesratsbank heute
wurde ramelow ist der ministerpräsident
von thüringen und auch natürlich ist er
bundesratspräsident und joachim stamm
ist da der stellvertretende
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen und jetzt gibt es
applaus den ich ihnen noch erklären muss
denn die belarussische
oppositionspolitikerin die ich an oskar
ist heute hier im deutschen bundestag
und wird jetzt gerade
vorüber schauen ja tatsächlich allen
fraktionen mit stehendem beifall bedacht
sie wird hier eine ganze reihe von
politischen gesprächen führen in berlin
heute und teilweise auch gestern schon
wie gesagt die abgeordneten haben sich
erhoben zu
ihren
namen aller kolleginnen und kollegen des
deutschen bundestages das haben sie am
applaus gerade bemerkt begrüße ich sie
sehr herzlich und wünsche mir dass auch
das volk von belarus in zukunft seiner
geschichte seine geschicke mit freien
und auch parlamentarischen debatten
gestalten wird
herzlichen dank für fahren in der
debatte fort und als nächste rednerin
für die spd fraktion hat sabine dittmann
das wort und sabine dittmar aber in der
letzten legislaturperiode
gesundheitspolitische sprecherin ihrer
fraktion
seit er die frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir legen heute
einen gesetzentwurf vor der den ländern
auch nach dem ende der feststellung der
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite die rechtssicherheit geben
wird beim anordnen von den nach wie vor
notwendigen corona schutzmaßnahmen mit
der erstmaligen feststellung einer
epidemischen lage hat der deutsche
bundestag im märz 2020 im
infektionsschutzgesetz ein sonderrecht
geschaffen ein besonderes für die
bundesregierung und für das
gesundheitsministerium um maßnahmen zur
bewältigung der pandemie auch per
rechtsverordnung anzuordnen
damit verbunden war auch die möglichkeit
für die länder schutzmaßnahmen
anzuordnen die mit teils schwerwiegenden
grundrechts einschränkungen verbunden
war und diesen verfassungsrechtlichen
ausnahmezustand wollen die fraktionen
der spd grüne und fdp beenden und die
entscheidung wieder ins parlament
das derzeit das derzeit von polen
richtiger ist sieht man auch daran dass
der
ressortverantwortliche
bundesgesundheitsminister genau dieses
vorgeschlagen hat die epidemische lage
nicht weiter zu verlängern und
vielleicht hat dobrindt erbringt
hausherr botschaft sollten sie dann noch
mal in den austausch stehen
gleichwohl gleich null ist die batterie
nicht vorbei sie ist nicht vorbei wir
sind mitten in der vierten welle wir
leben mit 50.000 neuinfektionen am tag
eine infektion szenario als bislang
nicht gekannten ausmaßes und die länder
unternehmen aktuell erhebliche
anstrengung und das infektionsgeschehen
den griff zu kriegen und sie wünschen
sich dafür so nicht weiterhin klare
rechtliche grundlagen und mit dem
vorliegenden gesetzentwurf stellen wir
sicher dass in den herzen der monaten
die erforderlichen und auch bewerten
instrumentarien weiterhin zum einsatz
kommen können maßgeblich abstandsgebot
3d 2d wird jene konzepte
kapazitätsgrenze
aber liebe bürgerinnen liebe bürger wir
wollen wir müssen uns weiterhin dafür
sorgen
dass die schwestern und verletzlichsten
in unserer gesellschaft so gut wie
möglich geschützt werden können
pflegebedürftige und kranke sollen
weiterhin besuch von ihren angehörigen
bekommen können kitas und schulen
sollten geöffnet und deshalb müssen wir
das umfeld dieser besonderen
schutzbedürftigen gruppen so sicher wie
möglich wir wollen sicher sie wollen
sicher dass beschäftigte ihre arbeit
bestmöglich geschützt sind und betriebe
verantwortungsvoll weitergeführt werden
können und deshalb sprechen wir in den
laufenden verhandlungen über notwendige
ergänzungen des gesetzentwurfs dazu
gehören die testpflicht die beschäftigte
und besucherinnen besucher in
pflegeeinrichtungen
wer als beschäftigter nicht gelesen oder
geimpft ist wer sich täglich testen
lassen müssen aber auch für geimpfte und
gelesen wird es in die wissen bereichen
regelmäßig verpflichtende tests geben
deshalb werden wir auch die kostenlosen
bürger tests wieder einführen
meine damen und herren kolleginnen und
kollegen was wir jetzt erleben
exponentielles infektionsgeschehen
regionen mit insolvenzen über 1000 1
verlassen die stationen pflegekräfte und
ärzte die am limit arbeiten
all das hat einen grund dies ist der
tatsache geschuldet dass 16 millionen
erwachsene und so kommen auf 5 millionen
jugendliche noch immer nicht geimpft
sind dass sich die mobilität mit
zunehmendem abstand zur impfung abnimmt
aber
auch dass wir zwischenzeitlich wieder
ein sehr viel besseres miteinander
erleben kollegin dittmer und ziel stand
kollegin dittmann erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der fdp-fraktion
meyerhans noch unsere insel sind
unsere intensivstationen sind voll mit
menschen die sich mit einer impfung
hätten schützen können als medizinerin
kann ich nicht logisch nachvollziehen
und erklären warum gehen angst vor
äußerst seltene nebenwirkungen bei einer
impfung warum diese angst schwerer wiegt
als die angst davor mit lungen versagen
und schweren langzeitfolgen auf der
intensivstation beatmung und
dabei nicht dabei
das heißt der kunde nie aufgehalten die
krise lautet kämpfen im flecken
schließen und beim bus dann schneller
werden lassen sie uns die bevorstehenden
intensiven beratungen über
fraktionsgrenzen hinweg dafür alles tun
damit kohler aus unserem leben aus
unserem alltag zurück gedrängt wird
sabine dittmann aus der spd-fraktion
auch sie war maßgeblich beteiligt an in
diesem gesetzentwurf der hier gerade
diskutiert wird er am montag in einer
anhörung kommt und am nächsten
donnerstag dann zu zweiter und dritter
lesung wieder hier ins parlament kommen
wird um dann auch abgestimmt zu werden
nächste rednerin achso diesen kleinen
hinweis noch eines jetzt an der spitze
des bundestags präsidiums bundestagsvize
präsidentin hat
bärbel bas abgelöst und jetzt nin
erwarten für juni ums fraktion nicht
verlängern sondern sie ende des monats
auslaufen lassen wollen ist ein völlig
falsches signal für den umgang mit der
pandemie in der aktuellen lage
und der
gesetzentwurf der hier vorgelegt wurde
und als großer befreiungsschlag
verkauft wird ist insofern paradox als
dass darin die maßnahmen die bislang auf
grundlage der notlage verhängt werden
konnten in abgespeckter unzureichender
form bis märz fort gelten sollen es ist
nicht mehr so dass alle drei monate die
notlage durch das parlament künftig
festgestellt werden kann aktuell kann
die geltung der epidemischen lage hier
im plenum nach abstimmung beendet und
mit kurzen vorlauf wieder eingesetzt
werden und künftig braucht es
veränderungen der maßnahmen eingesetzt
das ist für die eindämmung einer
pandemie ein viel zu behäbiges vorgehend
meine damen und herren
und mit den plänen
verkürzen auch die künftigen
koalitionäre auch wenn es hier anders
dargestellt wird die rechte des hohen
hauses gegeben sie nicht an das
parlament zurück wie es hier die fdp und
2 machen will auch das gehört zur
wahrheit dazu liebe kollegen
vor allem aber weiß der eingebrachte
gesetzentwurf einige lücken auf und
bleibt auch hinter dem zurück was gerade
heute in den reden vollmundig
angekündigt wurde ist fehlen klare
regelungen für 2g und 3g am arbeitsplatz
mit einem auskunftsrecht des
arbeitgebers sind auch die finanzielle
unterstützung von krankenhäusern dies
bisher nur angekündigt aber noch nicht
verankert und die länder rechte werden
eingeschränkt insgesamt kann man sagen
dass scheinbar mehr rücksicht auf
impfverweigerer genommen wird als auf
jene die sich zum wohle aller für eine
impfung entschieden haben meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren die pandemie
hat uns allen viel abverlangt und damit
wir mit der gebotenen vorsicht ein
bisschen mehr normalität in unserem
leben möglich machen können braucht es
verlässliche regeln die 2g und 3g
regelungen bieten solche voraussetzungen
und darum müssen wir auch auf sie
vertrauen können und nicht fürchten
müssen dass die person am nachbartisch
im restaurant einen gefälschten nachweis
vorgelegt hat doch da gibt es eben
strafbarkeitslücken die wir seit
längerem schon schließen wollen als
union jetzt endlich mit einbringung
unseres gesetzentwurfes haben auch die
ampel parteien diesem punkt aufgegriffen
die schritte gehen in die richtige
richtung aber sie reichen in der
gegenwärtigen situation nicht aus wir
fordern eine härtere bestrafung für
impfpass fälschungen und für die nutzung
dieser gefälschten dokumente meine damen
und herren sagen wir wie es ist man
merkt dass die drei parteien an spagat
schaffen müssen zwischen dem was grüne
und fdp lautstark in der opposition
gefordert haben dem was sie in den
koalitionsverhandlungen unter einen hut
bringen müssen und dem was die wirklich
zunehmend dramatische corona lage als
gebotenes handeln erfordert die rot
grün-gelbe selbstfindungsphase liebe
kollegen strahlt der eingebrachte
gesetzentwurf aus wir brauchen aber
führung und sicherheit und um diesen
unsicheren kurs im gegenzusteuern werden
wir uns als union auf im weiteren
parlamentarischen verfahren konstruktiv
einbringen vielen dank
vielen dank
[Applaus]
ich schließe die aussprache
interfraktionell wird überweisung der
gesetzentwürfe auf den drucksachen 15
und 27
an den hauptausschuss vorgeschlagen ich
gehe davon aus dass es keine weiteren
überweisungs vorschläge gibt dann
verfahren wir wie vorgeschlagen